في العشري من ابريل نيسان عام 2003 وبعد
يوم واحد من دخول القوات الامريكيه الى
بغداد
اقتحمت اول مجموعه من اللصوص المتحف
العراقي على مراى ومسمع من القوات
الامريكيه التي لم تحرك ساكنا في حينها
تعرض المتحف الوطني العراقي لاكبر عمليه
نهب استمرت ستا 36 ساعه ابانا عمليه
التغيير التي حصلت في العراق في عام 2003
تعرض المتحف العراقي لغونا ايقونه حضاره
وادي الرافدين الى عمليه السرقه والتخريب
والتدمير بعد عمليه الاحتلال التي حصلت
الى بغداد حيث تعرضت الاثار الموجوده داخل
صالات المتحف العراقي في اغلبها الى عمليه
التحطيم
وسرقه الاثار التي تحمل الارقام المتحف
العراقي في قاعات في القاعات
العديده سواء كانت السومريه وبابليه
واكديه واشوريه وحضاريه لكن كوارث الغزو
الامريكي عام 2003 لم تتوقف عند تدميري
ونهب مؤسسات الدوله واثار بلاد الرافدين
وانما تطور الى ظهور مافيات فساد منظمه
تغلغلت في عمق النظام الحاكمي وما تزال
الفساد المالي والاداري بات الظاهره
الاكثر خطوره وفتكا في العراق حيث ادى الى
سرقه مئات مليارات الدولارات من اموال
الدوله وقوت الشعب ماذا دفع بعض رؤساء
الوزراء في العراق لتشكيل هيئات ولجان
لمكافحه الفساد لكن من دون جدوى
ظاهره الفساد بشكل كبير وتحولت الى منظومه
هناك ترابح ما بين القوه السياسيه جميع
القوى الفاعله بدون استثناء اصبحت هاجسها
الاساسي
وهدفها الاساسي هو الثراء على حساب الوطن
والمواطن اصبحت منظومه الفساد منظومه
متناميه في جميع مؤسسات الدوله
بعد مرور 20 عاما على سقوط بغداد لم يستعد
العراق جميع اثاره المنهوبه لكنه بقي
اسيرا لوباء اخطر بكثير يتمثل بالفساد
الذي ينخر كل شيء في هذا البلد ما دفع
رئيس الوزراء محمد الشيعه السوداني لوصف
الفساد في بلاده بالجائحه
من بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه